Mila Kunis compares Ashton Kutcher to
bachelor in paradise star Jared Haven
add this to the list of reasons why Mila
and Ashton make the best couple ever
she might be an a-list star but Mila is
also a fan of ABC's Bachelor spin-off
bachelor in paradise
in fact she thinks hubby Ashton looks
like contestant Jared and even had him
tweet this side-by-side selfie out as
proof and seriously Ashton and Jared do
kind of look alike along with a pig
Ashton wrote quotes I'm trying to figure
out why Mila is making me take this
picture
Ashlee I echo who are you and who is
this guy fans of the show know that
during Monday night's episode Ashlee
said that she thought her crush Jared
looked like Ashton I mean like I think
he's kind of like the hottest Iverson in
any case Ashlee was clearly thrilled
about Ashton's tweet she responded
writing quote oMG just seen this hi
Ashton I'm Ashley
thanks for the side by side comparison
Mila Joe Jonas your turn
seriously Joe it's your move